this is easily what car looks like with
a caveat it's actually all wrong
this is actually all wrong oh let me I
wonder if anyone could spot it um I sort
of fence myself in I didn't have to do
this but I thought I could rub it all
off the side again but anyhow let me
tell you what's right about it first the
shades right the shape is right the
shape is right it's just like tan except
it's being reversed okay which which
shouldn't surprise you because it's the
reciprocal of tan the asymptotes x
equals zero degrees x equals 180 degrees
x equals 60 degrees the asymptotes are
also prime there's something else that's
wrong but anyone spotted what do you
mean wrath okay good well sure if you
caught that it's quite a subtle point
and you might see now why I said I
didn't have to do this to illustrate how
clock works I drew in the numerator and
the denominator so I'm doing if you want
to think about it this way with my two
graphical components on there I'm doing
other way the blue graph divided by the
green graph that helps me see okay where
are the asymptotes it's where the green
graph that you dominate up it's where
that's zero okay how are the other
things behavior well I can see how the
blue and green graphs are interacting
with regard to size but that immediately
tells you right for instance they're
easy parts like here here the numerator
blue is zero so I don't care what the
denominator is for non zero which is
gone so that's why it goes to zero at
ninety degrees however the other glaring
point is right here okay think about
that point that's what cause is equal to
sign so you actually know what that
angle should be right
so so that should be 45 degrees and at
that point cause the 45 is 1 over 2 sine
of 45 1 over 2 okay so if the view
berated the denominator are the same and
when you divide two numbers that are the
same you shouldn't get this you should
get one right which which I've already
put in is up here because that's we're
calling the sign on okay you might be
able to see why I decided to draw it
through here rather than up there
because if I had you're not there my
scale would have it you wouldn't be able
to see the curvature of caught properly
so I made an executive decision
okay but if you were and occasionally
this habit yeah that you get asked to
draw two graphs on the same set of axes
you got to make sure that this scale is
consistent with each other which at the
moment they're not but that's what it
looks like one last question
here's tan right his tab you'll notice
like we know what tan looks like so why
did I not just draw a tan and say well
it's equal to one on tan can any let's
see the reason car cut is more than just
one on ten yeah so notice how tan has
asymptotes right so if I take the
reciprocal of say that slightly degrees
there alright so what would happen here
when I take the reciprocal what would
what happened on this crap think again
look it's an asymptote it's a vertical
asymptote what does it mean about a
function when it has a vertical
asymptote
aha okay so here at denominator zero
means the graph doesn't exist so if I
were to graph the reciprocal of this
function that when I go down to 90
degrees I should have a discontinuity
can you see that because like what's the
reciprocal or something which doesn't
exist it doesn't exist so can exist here
right so you'd get this shape okay but
it does exist because cart is more than
just 1/10 it's cause on sign which is
perfectly defined at 90 degrees it's
zero okay so if you're wondering why
like why would I go through more graphs
when I already know what it should look
like and take its reciprocal it's to
avoid this alright which should be just
the same as if i graph if I ask you
graph this right you'd say yeah fine I
would just graph this what did I add to
no there's a difference
this guy looks like this just played all
linear function right the difference is
that this guy has a hole in the middle
because he can't equal 0 you see that
very very tiny difference but it's a
difference nonetheless